thick polar ice has lifted the  researchers ship off its keel the  Akademik shokalskiy hasn't been able to  move for four days Saturday morning a  Chinese icebreaker tried to clear a path  to open water but the sea ice proved too  thick now a second ship from Australia  is on the way I can still see it is  hanging in station it's just off their  starboard bow it's about seven nautical  miles away but it's basically waiting  now for one of the other icebreaker  vessels the Australian vessel Aurora  Australis to come and help support and  together the two we're hoping you'll be  able to break in despite the danger the  research team on board is staying  optimistic they are using the extra down  time to research their findings in  Antarctica the polar expedition spent  the past five weeks following the path  of Antarctic Explorer sir douglas mawson  they were on their way home on tuesday  when sea ice blocks their path